part of living with parkinson's can in
time mean losing independence in
particular the ability to walk a
possible solution could help patients
remain mobile when the body refuses
walter dixon was diagnosed with
parkinson's disease in 2019. my problem
is is freezing the movement and trouble
getting started you know i can once i
get going i'm good to go sometimes and
then if you if you the old adage about
can't walk through gum if i start
chewing a stick of gum i may stop you
know really literally it's called
freezing of the gate and it's defined as
a sudden onset of immobility the place i
freeze constantly as doorways and it's
very embarrassing to me to be to be that
obvious in public you know i don't like
it at all the reason that it happens is
because of a specific neural pathway in
the brain that gets damaged or
disconnected that makes it so that when
your brain is sending that signal to
initiate movement that signal just
doesn't get to the motor neuron
that are activating your muscles sidney
collins started to oro devices she
wanted to create a device which uses the
same visual and audio cues as physical
therapists it gives me something to look
at so to speak
triggers my brain to look down to laser
and try and put my foot through it or
kick it like that step into it yeah it
gives me something to step towards and
then in addition what that does helps to
trigger my thinking towards you know i
listen to that and i think to myself
step
step
step
look at the laser step stepping away i
go it's encouraging for colin i had read
about the impact i knew logically that
these visual and auditory cues worked
but seeing it happen was a whole
different thing
and life-changing for dixon
it helps steady me it helps me to walk
me the courage to do a lot of things i
wouldn't be doing now technology making
a difference one step at a time john
langler live local now